How do these massive oceans of snow and ice
stay on a mountain in the first place?
When an avalanche starts, is there anything
we can do?
The power of nature is devastating, as pictures
and video of the recent earthquake and avalanche
in Nepal illustrate, but avalanches don't
just happen during earthquakes, and, in fact,
are far more common than you think; but not
for the reasons you may think.
An avalanche is a falling mass of snow, ice,
and rock that tumbles rapidly down a mountainside.
They can be dangerous, and deadly.
These massive clouds of rock and frozen water
can reach 80 miles per hour (129 kph), sweeping
trees, buildings and even massive steam trains
out of the way.
Dry snow avalanches can reach speeds of more
than 200 miles per hour (322 kph).
Avalanches are formed because of the physics
inherent in the natural process of snowpack.
Mountains alter how air flows over the surface
of the planet.
When moist air hits a mountain it must either
go around, or up and over -- but to do either
it must CHANGE.
If it goes up, the air cools, and moisture
condenses into rain or snow.
As the tallest mountain in the world, Everest
collects a lot of cold wind and precipitation
as the air moves around and over it -- and
as the snow falls, it creates the conditions
for an avalanche.
Snow crystals, as you'd know if you're a subscriber
to DNews -- if you aren't come join us! -- come
in a few shapes.
Most are six pointed water crystals, which
lock together nicely.
When snow comes in contact with super-cooled
air, like it can on mountains, the snowflakes
form rime or, like, a frost on the edges -- sometimes
forming a gravel-like snow called graupel.
Different snow falls in different conditions,
forming specific layers on the mountainside.
The danger in an avalanche, aside from the
speed, is the sheer volume and mass of the
speeding snow.
In April of 2014, a MASSIVE formation weighing
31 and-a-half million pounds sloughed off
an Everest glacier, killing 16 sherpas.
And stories like this are relatively common
in many mountain-ranges across our planet.
Plus, once the snow stops falling, it sets
up like concrete and the weight compresses
the snowpack, meaning death often occurs from
injury or suffocation, aside from hypothermia.
Cartoons made me believe sound causes avalanches,
but while 90 percent of avalanches are caused
by a victim or a member of the victim's party,
it's not due to sound.
Avalanches are ACTUALLY caused simply by weight
of the snow thanks to gravity.
The snow is in three layers, the oldest most
packed-in snow on the bottom is compressed
and solid -- that's called the bed surface.
The middle layer is a weak layer of snow which
initiates the slide -- called the weak layer;
or failure layer; and then on top is the slab.
Slabs are new snow, or compressed and compacted
chunks of snow and ice which break off and
begin the avalanche.
When a slab sits on a failure layer, at JUST
the right slope -- between 35 and 45 degrees
-- the slab will break off.
Slabs range from 10 centimeters to several
meters thick.
This also means that avalanches are more common
after a new, heavy snow -- which can add a
lot of weight to an already-loose slab.
Though that is not the whole story in Nepal
-- where a 7.8 magnitude earthquake shook
the snow off the mountain.
And for more background on the geology of
that region and why Nepal is prone to earthquakes,
watch this DNews episode from Julia:
Ultimately, avalanches and earthquakes are
going to happen and once they do, there's
nothing to stop them.
But the more we understand them, perhaps the
better prepared we can be when these disasters
strike again.